yeah there's some things that are gonna
suck like the traffic when it comes back
it's been so nice getting everyone and
it's starting to come back it's time to
come back
I hit track though Dan's like what the
[ __ ] man yeah I thought you asked for
this dude talking all that [ __ ] you've
asked for this yeah it was the economy
open back up you asked traffic comes
back and then you guys like we're like
like I'm also thinking about like
eventually I want to buy a house when
where I live like I'm never gonna be
able to afford anything when like
Beverly Hills running that show like I'm
going out to like the desert 9 like I'm
out in like I'm driving around like
Agoura Hills it's nice that it's nice
nice shell Canyon all those are we
thinking I'm driving around there and
I'm like look at houses like two million
bucks and I'm like not now and not soon
but I'm like eventually that will be a
reality but in my neighborhood I walk my
house it's like 20 million but I'm like
yeah that's normal Hills ridiculous
ridiculous nice it's ridiculous I saw
the only one that really lives over
there I know but that's of yeah they
don't want to know yeah most successful
comedians are pigs to that that's all
Whitney that I'm like yeah we're
monsters like these guys made their
money like Kazakh Stan with oil dude
these guys like wait a minutes in that
Bell Canyon the woman speak at the table
thank you my woman is in back house
right now when I need one of wives I go
back there I will hire her make child
and then but she knows is be a Calabasas
they put the women on the TV it's no no
no no I like old school there I kind of
like a little I like both schools nice
but yeah dude I could get really into
like some weird desert thing would you
be let out a poolroom I could get real
thrashing me too did you leave
California yes yeah he's living on
settlements not soon but I would be very
down for tax I'm open to it I love Texas
I like Texas I love outside of Dallas I
like Dallas a lot what about Austin I
like Austin
I like San Antonio I like them all um
yeah if I go I like to I like Texas
allowing to live in Houston I don't like
Houston it's not that I got her too fat
it's uncomfortable and I'm a big guy I'm
fat guy but Houston is the kind of fat
where it's like it's on control hi dizzy
Lanza I get worried it's people that
look like they're gonna explode yes it's
Noren mask it's like yeah well it's a
problem it's a Brooke Chrysler I was
opening for him and we sat down in a
restaurant in Houston and we're just
looking around like well we're great we
should just start rewarding ourselves
yeah but he's this big but yeah Austin's
great Dallas is great here's one thing I
like Callie too though I love California
and the one thing I love the ocean I
love the beat like that's great the one
thing about California though is you got
a beast of a state tax right and Texas
you don't exactly think of the money
with it yeah that's a Florida and Texas
if we all went down there you just we
had a whole squad done yeah you gotta
you gotta get a bunch of people to do it
yeah who would be in I don't know
Julio's not going daliyah's not gonna go
Rogan we'll go we'll go go Rogan go
Allen Oh golly go see like Oh we'll go
see oh we go yeah baby Joey Diaz we go
oh I don't know I don't know I don't
know either what about the New York guys
no no they're not going it wouldn't they
won't even leave New York I know it
won't leave New York and a payday this
is a crazy time to talk Chris come down
yeah I do it every day really I tell me
what are you doing what are you doing
I'll tell you this New York people are
so crazy right now they're shaming
people who left during the pandemic I'm
like why are what they're like they're
guilting people that left to be safe
like you should have fought this yeah I
will remember who stayed you didn't shut
up shut the [ __ ] up
that's Sony people want to live get out
of that [ __ ] that weird masochistic
relationship you have with that city
where they it's just a rule remember who
stayed here and died oh well you will
remember who went on a ventilator it's
like great some people want to get out
they've kids they don't want to [ __ ]
be in a rat tunnel of disease you have
you seen them eight look this I Love New
York but it's enough sand off I mean
I've suggested and I suggested this and
this is not a joke and it's not and I
don't want anyone got
but I've said because the disease
outbreak is so bad and I Love New York
leave there's no way to gas the people
and leave the building's the
architecture is so gorgeous but could we
gas the people in their homes this is my
question and I'm not not being shitty
about I'm not being a dick about it I
just think something needs to be done
yeah uh-huh
yeah look how many people are moving
from California to Texas right now it's
insane a lot right tax is like hey
Colorado is cool but he's just live on a
[ __ ] and yeah that's where I'm from
Colorado much to my telling people are
moving to Colorado - yeah I could never
move Denver and at its height was got
like 30,000 a month yes man in will you
miss the beach though with the ocean I
kind of like the ocean you know I'm not
there done I mean I'll go in the light
by the ocean but I'll go in like once a
week I'll just pop down to Hermosa Beach
go and I like the idea that I can do
that but that's what it is I like that
there's mountains
oh [ __ ] like you're you can get to
everything then there's the
entertainment business yeah but I'm not
unlike movies and TV so I could kind of
relocate any but you know what I'm I do
feel that that's that will change when
like I think that's already starting to
change like not immediately but like I
think more opportunities you're gonna
open up for people that are big in this
realm and then yeah man dude if we all
did a movie we would you know how many
people would watch it it should be under
our umbrella it should be under our
control though we should have license to
NBC or yeah but why not Bui not sella
Netflix for real money Netflix you could
sure yeah I mean I the way I think about
it I'm like if we all made a movie and
then sold it to Netflix why not 100% you
know no that's what I think I'm like I'm
like you know I'm like why not second
bullet I love podcast but I also want to
do other shit's why make those videos
it's like I want to do other stuff I get
little bored
yeah you're great you'll have your own
show soon then on the network but also
if you think about our group of guys if
the our a network because that's what be
here right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tone oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]